oh yeah oh yeah
no no no hi my name is vivian
hi guys my name is shawn my name is
jessica and today we are going to try
every single hot cheeto flavor thing
we could find
uh you want me to tell you about hot
cheetos all right well
first off i am a flaming hot snack
myself i am
flaming i am hot and i'm a snack
i love the flaming hot cheetos community
i mean i feel like you're a specific
person
if you love flavory hot cheetos as much
as i do that's great
this is i love this quick disclaimer the
snacks we will be trying today are the
ones that specifically say
flaming hot on them all right here we go
what do we do first the original the
icon the legend
we have the nun the only the cheetahs
flaming hot
oh let's do some of that oh look at that
so good i mean really classic good
put a little do i like it
no i love it next we have none other
than
cheetos flaming hot with limou
nope no no no
it's just so good i want to cry i don't
like lemons i don't like limes i don't
like
fruits even though i am a fruit
[Applause]
hot cheeto pups flamin hot cheeto puffs
now these ones
because they're already mostly air yo i
go through those in like
a day these things are huge
oh my god i don't remember it being this
big
too much puff
so good it's literally just air but it's
so good air
full of flavor love the texture let's do
more
next we have chester's popcorn i have no
idea what a popcorn is look at this
it's airy it's soft it's light but still
that little hot kind of kick to it
so good next we have the chester's
cleaning out fries
is chester's the cheeto man okay this is
bomb i love this
i would eat this a lot in college not
gonna lie also that's why i gained the
freshman 50.
ah it smells like college smells like a
lot of bad choices
i usually buy these when they don't have
the classics i'm never looking for i
think these are my least favorite ones
this might be my least favorite yeah it
just didn't really
taste like much
okay this is the cheetos flamin hot bite
it is the healthier version low-key i
just like to eat this because i can eat
the whole bag
and not feel bad about myself
i don't feel satisfied
it doesn't feel like i'm eating junk
food and if i'm eating chips
i want it to taste like junk food don't
sleep on this flavor because low key is
good
put it in your salad next we have
fritos flamin hot honestly i'm not a big
fan of fritos
unless they're the barbecue twists oh i
love those
it doesn't actually have a lot of
flaming hot flavor to it these kind of
just taste like burritos
if you want that flaming hot
satisfaction maybe not from this one
[Applause]
so next we have doritos splitting hot
nacho
oh this is a proper chip my expectations
are really high
i don't know the flavors are alright but
i was looking for
more flamin hot i thought this one was
about to slay dragons and
next doritos flaming hotly mold
now this i would immediately want to buy
these
it looks toxic what's this whole newly
mod thing
i don't even know what limon is
this is a chip
[Music]
yep yes nope
nope nope yes yes yes yes yes
no no no um
yep well i don't get it like is it
supposed to be good
bunions never knew there was a flaming
hot version so this is gonna be
interesting
i have a feeling this might be my
[Music]
favorite
super subtle not gonna lie it kind of
tastes just like a regular onion chip or
onion chip
if you love funyuns you will enjoy this
but
i was wrong it's not my favorite next up
we have
cheetos popcorn flamin hat
and even though cheetos made popcorn oh
look at this look at this
[Music]
it tastes like soy sauce
no come on cheetos get your ish together
next up we have smart food flamin hot
white cheddar i've never had this before
i didn't know that they had like a
flaming hot version of this
wow
what yeah it's more like white cheddar
with like a pinch of lemon cloth
you know it's like
[Applause]
i like this one better but i guess this
one works too
next we have lay's flaming hot
this smells like barbecue so like it
smells like
barbecue i don't know why this why would
why is it smelling like barbecue real
talk it tastes like lay's barbecue with
an extra kick
there is not enough seasoning or flavor
on this one this like
next up kettle cooked flamin hot it is
basically the same thing i just have but
now
kettle cooked it looks like this is
going to set your mouth on fire
but let's see if it actually does
oh good crunch
if you really love kettle chips then you
are going to go crazy for this flaming
hunt
they're very good i love the texture
next up
really no no
no who asked for this i didn't even
think they made pickle
dickle jesus i didn't even know they
made
pickled flavored wait what
let's try this
nope next flaming hot ruffles
let's go ruffles is like okay like i'll
eat it
if like there's nothing else but at the
same time like who eats ruffles as their
first choice
i love ruffles i hope they don't taste
just like regular ruffles i hope they
actually do the job
flaming hot style
see i like i don't even taste the rub oh
no i taste always taste the hot now
okay this is new for me this is the
flaming hot asteroid
it's so little
yeah it's so small that i didn't feel
like i ate anything
like i don't taste anything i just like
it i need more flamin hot in here
the very best for last my favorite
that black bag baby when i eat hot
cheetos
i expect to be tortured in a couple
hours
i'm speechless because i love flipping
hot foods
but loki i'm like a little i mean
you already know what it is i love this
i love this
i love this scared
what did i say it's a classic texture
[Music]
oh that's good oh it burns but it burns
so good
yo maybe i'm into like s m i hope that
was entertaining
and um next time on my 600 pound life
flaming hot cheetos edition
oh no it's all followed on my own
you